tous les jours geneviève leclerc se
rendant ainsi h et celle des pour voir
jacques son époux les cas de kevin 19 se
sont chevauchées dans l'unité de soins
où réside son mari résultat il a été
isolé dans sa chambre pendant deux mois
y a maigri ya plus plu du tout de plus
il 0 pas parce que pas capable de le
dire mais il ya plus vraiment le goût de
vivre c'est clair sans activité sans
sortie sans bénévoles pour aider les
capacités physiques et cognitives de
nombreuses personnes vivent ch et celle
des ou en résidence privée pour aînés
ont drastiquement chuté bien des
familles rapportent des confits demande
étage complet pendant dix jours on sent
que des mesures ne sont pas en phase
avec le nouveau contexte c'est-à-dire
celui du variant au micron et le très
grand taux de vaccination de nos aînés
et l' isolement pourrait s'avérer
parfois plus mortel que lakovic 19 c'est
ce que rapporte une étude américaine
quinze mille résidences pour aînés ont
été analysés celle avec les mesures les
plus sévères ont répertorié moins de
décès liés à la coved 19 mai au fil des
mois c'est même résidence ont constaté
une hausse des mortalités non reliées à
la coved 19 je ne crois pas qu'il soit
comme et rationnelle de quand il ya des
éclosions ponctuelle de d'avoir des
mesures d'isolement ont tué halle de
courte durée quelle est cette étude
vient nous montrer c'est que des mesures
à moyen long terme de confinement sont
vraiment néfaste de visiteurs par jour
sont désormais autorisées dans le ch et
celle des et quatre visiteurs par jour
dans les résidences privées pour aînés
mais pour de nombreux patients qui ne
peuvent ni bouger ni parler ces
allègements ne changeront rien car le
retour des services adaptés à leurs
besoins sont toujours suspendus c'est
une partie de leur santé qui est aussi
importante que le côté physique
physiologique
et on leur a enlevé son île simard
isabel rochât radio canada montréal